members and visitors
agenda item one is apologies for absent
members we've received apologies from
council mrs christine mason and
councillor james newport members are
there any other apologies
thank you
agenda item 2 substitute members
members we have council chris stanley
substituting for councillor james
newport
agenda item 3 non-members attending
members we have council simon wooten
councillor mrs cheryl rowe councillor
david sperring councillor daniel f day
councillor mrs judy gooding
councillor ian ward councillor simon
smith councillor mike webb and
councillor arthur williams will be
attending tonight's meeting
members also would you please welcome
council chris hossack the leader of
brentwood borough council
and
brentwood councillors ms maria pearson
councillor charles nolan
and councillor gary white who are also
attending our meeting this evening
thank you
moving on to agenda item four minutes of
the meeting held on the 30th of november
2021
are the minutes agreed members
okay those are agreed
the gender item five to receive any
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
okay none indicated thank you we now
move on to agenda item six which is the
pre-scrutiny of proposed
report to the council
regarding the strategic partnership with
brentford sorry brentwood borough
council
but before i invite councillors whitten
and councillor hossack to present
there's a couple of
points that i would like to make
so
i will invite
councillors wooten and councillor
hossack
to present to the committee
we will then members will then have the
opportunity to raise questions
we'll then move to the
members
making any recommendations and what i i
would ask you to please
be succinct when you are making these
recommendations
could i also ask you to make sure that
you reference the page and the paragraph
number in the report to which you refer
it will make it easier for the officers
to then
take down the recommendation
we will then have a short break while
the
officers collate those recommendations
and we will then come back display the
recommendations on the screen
get those agreed and then move to a vote
and we will move
on block so we're not going to
vote on each recommendation once we've
agreed that the recommendations of what
we've um
stated we will then move to a vote on
block
does anyone have any questions on that
okay thank you i'd like now to invite
the leader of the council
council simon wooten uh to present the
report and also he will be assisted
where necessarily by councillor chris
hossack simon
chairman thank you very much indeed
chairman thank you very much indeed for
the
opportunity to present to uh members
tonight members thank you
much
[Music]
okay
chairman take three
thank you very much indeed chairman for
the invitation this evening and the
opportunity for both uh councillors
hossack and myself
to be able to present to members of your
committee tonight i think before we move
to the presentation it might be helpful
just to set out a little bit of history
of where we have come from uh to where
we are tonight
it was july 2020 that i was elected to
be leader of this authority
and a few days after i had become leader
i had a discussion with the then
managing director
sean scratton who
said to me he said look simon you know
you're a new leader um i've been
thinking about that wonderful thing
called retirement having hit that sort
of age
and i've been doing this job for a while
now and it may be a little bit of a time
for a change for me
as well as you for as a new leader
you'll have your new vision
what you want to achieve
and so we had a sensible discussion
and sean decided to retire
so i scratched my head and realized that
was my first um
little issue to deal with which was the
recruitment of a new chief executive or
managing director
and as i say that happened in july right
in the midst of the early stages of
covid
when huge pressures on local authorities
are delighted when angela hutchings
stepped into the breach as our interim
managing director stroke chief executive
so thank you to you angela for
everything that you did for the next few
months in fact
sean stayed there until the 31st of
october so i'm a little bit ahead of
myself because sean
gave total commitment and support during
a very difficult time for all councils
during covid and as i say first of
november
angela
took over in an interim capacity
and again we scratched their heads and
put a paper together which appeared in
in council really looking at options and
those options really provided three
alternatives one was really replace like
for like
or two restructure
the top team
or three actually explore the
opportunity for partnership
and it was the partnership idea that
really appealed to me because you will
remember members that we were also at a
time when central government was talking
about local government reorganization
and
certainly i was looking and thinking
little old rochford
and other district and borough councils
given the background of cuts
budget constraints
how are we actually going to survive in
the longer term so i recognized that
there was a real opportunity to explore
the possibility of partnership
and it was in december 2020 that i was
given authority with
the then interim managing director to
look around within a radius of about
30-40 miles
of here
to look at the opportunities that there
might be for partnership well if you go
too far to the east you end up in the
sea so really you can only go west
and discussions were had
with
various authorities but i have to say
partnering
didn't seem likely with south end or
thorac because as unitary authorities
they have a different range of
responsibilities being unitary so i have
to say didn't look in that direction
uh bazilan
thought about basilan but to be honest a
bit of political turmoil there at the
time um a
predominantly industrial area
and a different socioeconomic makeup
there
which left
brentwood and castle point
discussions were had with castle point
and i'll be honest they didn't really go
too far um it just felt
that there wasn't really the um joint
approach and then
we had a discussion with brentwood and
you know it was initially a very
cautious discussion you know we've been
thinking about this from my point of
view i was looking for a
chief executive
to take the authority forward
and but then as we chatted
and initially the walls are up
because you know
you're very parochial you're very
protective of your own areas and and we
we had uh
early discussions i think at that point
before we move to the presentation i'm
going to ask councillor chris hossack to
view things from his perspective because
that's really where we take up the story
of uh
initially working with brentwood
council
thank you simon and um let's try and put
this in front actually i notice when you
turn your head away pretty much vanishes
the voice um so thank you simon and just
take this opportunity to say good
evening to everybody my name is chris
hossack i'm the leader of brentwood
council i've been a counselor there for
too long since 2003 and i've been the
leader there for about two and a half
years which is just about as long as you
can take to be honest but that's a
that's another story we'll see where
that goes i just don't worry leadership
in this project if it goes forward is
absolutely yeah it's absolutely key but
just to give you the flip side as
simon's outlined as to when we sort of
were on the receiving end of that
conversation
um interestingly uh we jonathan has been
our chief exec for just over two years
now and jonathan as you as you know
prior to that had come from a a joint
position anyway in in suffolk so i was
quite familiar with the ways of joint
working between different districts
and from my perspective while simon
approached us around
the initial and fairly simple idea of
just sharing a joint chief exec actually
when you start to think beyond that you
start to recognize that it could present
other opportunities and you'll see those
will be laid out in this short
presentation that we'll give in a moment
so we were quite open to the
conversation
why were we open to the conversation
well across
the council network particularly the
district council network
uh finances are a challenge
sustainability is a challenge for all of
us
and sometimes particularly the small and
the minnows in the pond uh where you're
often running off relatively small
budgets compared to some of the bigger
fish in the pond uh are probably going
to feel the pinch first and we know
uh the government uh over
many years
now since the reduction or elimination
as we've got as revenue support grants
etc have really tasked councils to
pave your own way be creative be
innovative
we get all sorts of challenges around
commercialization and generating
commercial income but one of the other
ways in which you can do it is actually
looking at partnership working
and looking at ways to improve your
sustainability and resilience in that
way so we were really open to it and i
have to say the conversation was really
easy with simon and has subsequently
been really easy with with angela and
other officers
and other another members that i've met
and members of my team that have equally
met so
so far so good i think the big part
about anything like this is the ability
to have a relationship where you can
relate to the other people in the uh in
the other party that's when i say the
other party don't make that political
sense but i mean the other group
um
so uh it's it felt good the conversation
was easy to be had and uh we are where
we are now we've done some work over the
last six months
uh really since jonathan was
appointed as joint chief on an interim
basis and we're now coming towards the
end of that agreed period um and
what we'll present to you in a moment is
kind of the commun
culmination sorry
of the of the work that we've been doing
to this point and this is a really
important milestone tonight so i'm
looking forward to this process we went
through a similar process last night in
brentwood uh which we agreed to take
forward um
to ordinary council with a few
recommendations not many and they were
all good recommendations
and i'm sure i won't preempt them and
say what they were because i think you
guys will probably come up with a
similar
way of thinking tonight but we'll see
where that goes
so um so far so good really important
milestone tonight i think ahead of
what goes forward towards the end of the
month
so that that's just it from me and uh
really pleased to be here and to meet
you all so thank you for the time you're
giving
so we moved to the uh presentation uh on
the screen
and um
i think already we've developed a logo a
a bespoke logo
and this is all about
the creation of one
officer team
one culture
and two very sovereign councils
but one partnership
and that was always
at the outset our objective
there was to be no dilution of
sovereignty
and
this is really sort of setting the scene
in terms of the following
slides on the presentation so if we move
to introduction please
so
i
spoke in the introduction that we got to
december and then of course there were
discussions with other councils i've
mentioned that
but having decided
the concept of partnering with brentwood
a paper was brought to
rocha district council on the 20th of
july brentwood borough council on the
28th of july
authorizing us to really proceed uh with
a strategic partnership and
see what we could do in terms of working
together
at that stage didn't really know how it
would shape um and uh but
the one
person that was going to oversee all of
this for us was going to be jonathan
stevenson
and tonight is really the culmination of
a huge amount of work that has been done
by members and officers to reach the
position that we're in
tonight
and a memorandum of understanding is in
your papers tonight
which captures the operational
opportunities that we
we have
shared service architecture with the
consultants who were engaged to help us
and
align objectives
and we've had a number of meetings at uh
member level at officer level at mixed
member and officer
level
so that we could sort of thrash out what
the real red lines were in terms of
moving forward
so this handbook and it seems rather
grand title for a set of slides but it
does actually set out at high level what
the objectives are to bring
the strategic partnership
to real life a lot of talk
a lot of setting the um
setting the scene at this stage
so if we move on to
the next slide if we may
and
so financial sustainability
i think we're all fed up with sitting
each year in our budget sort of saying
well what services have we got to cut
there's a number of non-statutory
services that we do as authorities but
we quite like doing them because it's
about servicing our residents supporting
them
and it's really tough when you've
actually got to
cut non-statutory services
it's also very tough when you've
actually got to look at your head count
and it becomes a little tedious year
after year and what this partnership
will clearly give us is the opportunity
for
economies of scale
in terms of
local government resilience moving
around the clock on that uh slide
resilience we see this as a huge
opportunity
to take some of the ongoing challenge of
recognizing that as an authority rotary
small brentwood is small and there are
lots of
councils around the country that are
small and i would suggest will face
challenge in one way or another over the
coming years
what this partnership does is it
actually
becomes quite attractive to look at
the joint arrangements between
brentwood and rochford to improve
resilience and actually create a bit of
envy by those councils that haven't
taken this sort of step
it provides greater opportunity
and retention
development of staff greater interest
to motivate and interest staff
let's not kid ourselves that within the
local government set up um a little old
rockford um
which
sits sort of somewhere near south end
and somewhere near brazil
perhaps may not be the most attractive
of places to come and work especially if
you're
geographically
remote but what we want to do is
actually
create an environment where we turn
around and sort of
build a reputation where people want to
come
and work with us and we have a
competitive
environment where lots of people
are really wanting to come and work for
us
we believe that we can be a stronger and
more influential regional voice already
chris and i have had contacts with
people sort of saying to us yeah what
you're doing is really innovative in the
modern in the modern time
it is just a fact that when you
combine some of your services you can
achieve better efficiencies and you can
gain economies of scale that is just a
simple fact
there is an optimum size to which you
can go to
before you start to lose the support to
residents
but we believe this partnership will
actually strengthen our support to
residents which is paramount and
important in all of this
and
it's about overcoming challenges
maximizing opportunities
the word i struggled on last night so
we'll have another go at it
entrepreneurship
i achieved it tonight an ambition it's
about having that vision that excitement
about working and being a member within
this authority
and actually feeling good vision and
ambition why shouldn't we have vision
and ambition
and we believe there's more that we can
do as a partnership
to sovereign councils
but working together and working alone
next slide please
so why rochford and brentwood we've
touched on that already but both are in
south essex we're both within the asella
partnership and a seller itself
is much um clearer in terms of its
objectives and what it is seeking to do
to improve uh the lives of people in
south essex with five very distinct
ambitions and
structure within it
so
that's a seller indeed
councillor hossack he's chair of
a seller and i'm vice chair
so
that's a little bit of a coincidence
where this partnership is concerned but
uh
there we are
so both have a mixed economy of
in-source and outsourced services
for example brentwood in source their
leisure we outsource it
they insult their waste collection we
outsource ours
so there's no perfect solution but we
hope that we can learn from each other
and perhaps build on the opportunity to
decide what will always be best for our
respective authorities
the
thing that actually legally makes sure
this continues to be a partnership
is the fact that we have no
administrative boundary we cannot
legally come together as one authority
and i think that will be actually
reassuring for our residents
both authorities have a very similar
size net revenue budget of the order of
about 10 million pounds each
both are actually district councils um
so there is parity in their local
government status albeit that one is a
borough council and one is a district
council
and as i alluded to a little earlier
both have similar socio economic makeup
and economics within our communities and
there's significant commonality we
believe in terms of objectives on the
part of our residents
so at that point i'm going to hand over
to
chris to complete the presentation thank
you
thank you simon
okay
so i i won't read this for but they bait
him because you've obviously got the
presentation in front of you and you've
got it in your packs as well but just a
couple of things that i just might draw
on and maybe emphasize a bit uh the
vision that this is what we've been
working together to create a sort of um
as two uh
members of this proposed partnership
coming together brentwood officers and
members and rochford officers and
members um
obviously we're looking for an enduring
partnership
if you we're not going to go into this
thinking it's a short-term thing we have
to we're going to invest into it
there's an expectation that it will
endure and it will work but we maintain
that to sovereign uh council approach
that's absolutely part of the vision
it's part of our key principles you'll
see all that in your in your
documentation uh but with a unified
officer team and i think that's largely
where the uh where the opportunity
where the opportunity arrives uh in that
there might be some other points on
there but if you bring an officer team
together if you think about it
when you work
you know perhaps in your professional
capacity and you work for a team of say
five people and you look around i've
been doing this 20 years i've been doing
this 10 years you all of a sudden start
to tut up that maybe you've got 100
years of experience in the room and if i
did that just across brentwood as an
organization we would have hundreds or
probably several thousand years of
experience
in in the organization and then you
mirror that with rockford and there'll
be different experiences all of a sudden
your
exposure to the level of experience is
just really
really rocketed so i think that's a real
strength of a unified office team
the partnership
will deliver a greater combined capacity
and one of our key visions that we
continuously improve you know we don't
just come together and stay where we are
we need to move forward with what we've
got
local identity is key uh for us it'll be
rochford uh
residents have their own
issues and an identity wish to maintain
and in the same way uh brentwood
residents will feel the same but
ultimately if i move to the other the
square just middle on the right uh
it's all it is about integration but the
key point just to to mention there is
integration of back office also um you
know what happens in the accounting
department
or or in the way electoral services run
or whatever should be
not not not something that actually the
public need to feel or feel a breeze on
in terms of any change it's back office
it does a job it does it efficiently it
does it cost effectively
but actually from a from a customer
point of view from a resident point of
view they shouldn't really be able to
feel the difference and that's a big
person what we do and that brings me on
to the bottom left we were together in
your fantastic museum in raley high
street and we were talking about all of
this in a very organizational way and
talking about management structures and
all these sort of things
and the comment is really if it's not if
the people on
in out the window in the high street the
people who live in in this district
don't feel the difference i don't feel
the benefit what's the point of doing it
and of course there are key benefits to
that because if we've got sustainable
councils that can deliver services
continue to deliver services and indeed
take the principle of continuous
improvement then they should feel the
benefit of this partnership so it it we
shouldn't lose sight of the fact that
it's people first
and that includes internal people first
as well you know there should be benefit
to the to the people who work in both
these organizations as we come together
i talked a little bit about depth of
skills and experience already so i won't
repeat that
but the other key part of the vision is
that it's an equitable partnership it
brings financial sustainability but
balance and risk but also
balancing rewards as well which we'd
hoped it would be and i'll probably
touch on those
in a moment um thank you
so
one of the one of the i'm not saying one
of the others like that's another thing
but it's actually key you know what are
the objectives for this partnership as
we come together
should we come together by the end of
this month subject to a political
decision that is
um what are the objectives that we want
to deliver on so financial
sustainability i think is probably where
it started and even even in its own
right that would be a perfectly adequate
objective but there's more
more to it than that uh financial
sustainability of course is not just for
sustainability's sake but it's to
deliver services and continue to do
those
and there's services that are valued you
know
sometimes you have to look at things and
say well if nobody feels the benefit of
that you've got to ask the fundamental
question in these times what are you
doing it for
and that may be conversations we could
have down the line
lead the way to improve our local
environment uh we've got we we
absolutely put this in about acting
locally and contributing globally um
we're only small districts relatively
but i always take the view and i talk to
this when we talk about the
environmental issues and the climate
change agenda in brentwood if everybody
did their small thing locally within
their own district within their own
neighborhood and if everybody did that
globally it would make a difference so
that's quite a big thing for us so it's
absolutely right for any local authority
anywhere in the world actually to be
thinking about the environmental gender
right now
it's not something we cannot afford to
not incorporate in our strategic
priorities
um housing is key simon's already
alluded to it we have a different
approach to yourselves we have two and a
half thousand council houses in stock
and so we have our own as a landlord our
own housing to maintain but of course
we're all in the business of
needing to
unfortunately or otherwise whatever your
view is growth can be uncomfortable but
we know there is a need to deliver
housing particularly affordable housing
uh particularly across south essex so
that's something that is absolutely a
priority that we can't
avoid
within this we must do that and of
course
all the infrastructure in the world is
great but everything whether their homes
roads schools hospitals doctor surgeries
are all there to improve the quality of
life and well-being of the residents
that live in both of our district areas
and then finally
we want to create opportunities for
economic growth we've driven this agenda
pretty hard in the last two two years
particularly our dad since jonathan's
been with us in brentwood
it's about delivery it's about looking
for opportunities and we are fortunate
in brentwood and you've sampled this
over the last six months that we have a
chief exec that actually is very
business minded i will say that i know
he's sitting to my right but
seize opportunities and things and i
think that could be a great asset to you
guys in rockford as we've we've we've
seen that in the last
two years or so uh in brentwood it's not
that we didn't do commercial before but
i certainly think we've got a much more
commercial mindset
both in terms of sweating our own assets
as an organization to make them work and
make them earn for us but actually
assets within the district you know what
can we do
uh to actually create jobs and
employment space and what can we do to
improve infrastructure assignments and
to attract people to want to work in
rochford and brentwood
so there are pretty strategic objectives
i think if i said housing environment
quality services
quality of life and financial
sustainability you could probably plug
them into any council in the uk and they
would work so they will not be
disjointed from any local priorities
that rochford already had i'm pretty
convinced of that and they certainly
do mirror we've got our own corporate
objectives but they pretty much mirror
those for brentwood so it's a good fit
is is the point i'm making there
is there anything else after that
yeah just the last slide i think you'll
be pleased to know
uh just again i'll draw some
key points out of this the key
principles that we agreed
um and i'll just draw the salient points
out of each thing political autonomy is
absolutely key
um
rochford has its own council and its own
elected members that are accountable to
the public and will continue to make
their own decisions
uh as as as brentwood does and the
moment the public don't like the
decisions you're making the public will
make the choice who represents them it's
as simple as that and that political
autonomy will remain
uh each council will retain its own
constitution uh so the way in which you
make those decisions uh is is your own
business frankly probably not dissimilar
to brentwood's constitution in many ways
but it's your constitution in the same
whether it's brentwood's
and of course uh fiscal independence set
your own budgets set your own council
tax uh challenging times at the moment
um there may be ways that we look at
things and discuss together and
collaborate around certain financial
decisions because harmony could could
well be important and significant in
some decisions we make but nonetheless
each council sets its own budget
going to the local democracy
elements of the slide you see in the
middle just a couple of points have
already made
made rather um
you know
you as a council here elected to speak
up for rochefort residents first and
foremost that's the priority same for us
from brentwood that doesn't change
why do we do that because it's about
locality it's about place so it's all
about developing your local ideas here
and encouraging residents to develop
local ideas you know local councils are
place leaders facilitators
for for members of the public that come
forward sometimes with great ideas and
sometimes we've with lots of good ones
but either way you want to be an ear to
those and be willing to develop those
local ideas
um and then the
quite a significant point around the
power of veto uh neither council will be
forced to do anything frankly that it
doesn't want to do whether it's a policy
or accept a risk or change a priority
that again
is part of your the rules around
sovereignty that rochford does what it
needs to do as does brentwood but the
beauty of the partnership is that we get
to discuss and say what would you think
if we did that or if we did this how
would that affect you if we did this
together could we get better reward and
i think that's the beauty of this but
nonetheless when it comes down to it
uh
sovereignty is is a key principle for
for this partnership
and then finally um
around the finances
a couple of rules that we talked about
here a couple of principles
we've used the phrase
benefits should be shared to the
satisfaction of both councils i think we
really start from the premise that if
there's a saving to be made
or a reward to be gained we should look
to share 50 50 but of course that might
not we i can't think of a particular
example but it might be as you get into
the detail that's not necessarily the
case so you you simon's talked about
different structures if we were doing
something with housing and we run our
own housing stock you guys don't so is
there a bit of a nuance in that that
maybe means that we have a conversation
but whatever we do we've done to the
satisfaction of both councils but i
think the starting point has got to be
50 50. uh and of course
no council would be obliged to break an
existing contract which is a
solid point because of the way
we've got differences between some key
services that we in source and outsource
so
so that's they're some of the key
principles that really as it says at the
top of the slide underpin
uh the basis of the partnership so that
was me i just wanted to sort of add a
bit and draw out some of the thoughts in
the document i hope you found that
useful and chair [ __ ] pass back to
you thank you for allowing us to address
your committee thank you council button
councillor hossack for setting the scene
for us
um members we're now going to move on to
the questions
and
as i said at the beginning of the
meeting
please would you reference the page and
the paragraph number in the report if
appropriate
and i know the first question counselor
mrs shaw please
thank you chris thank you simon for a
very good presentation um
page 6.15
2.2
item e
greater scope to retain and develop the
talented staff we have
across the two councils which completely
agree with but in audit we already share
uh a gentleman from basildon
so will this carry on or are we going to
now merge uh talent with
um richard and
brentwood please thank you
chairman thank you very much indeed
now
clearly it is very tempting when we have
a report in front of us like this
to think about the
stages take moving forward but there is
absolutely no intention to change what
we do immediately
we want to keep
those arrangements and i call them
arrangements
that are currently in place that are
working well
and it may well be
that
through discussions
with brentwood in time they say actually
you're doing that better than we are
so there is no intention to make any
changes uh everything that we do will be
considered uh and will be assessed and
object objectively reviewed the
difference is that we will have
discussions with brentwood on things
that we've got like that partnership
with bazilan and i'm sure that they will
have discussions with us and the
objective is to always try and do the
best
because the reality is and i talked
about walls coming down earlier the
great thing is that the walls have come
down and we're talking very openly about
things that we might have been a little
parochial about in the past
because it's you know a competitive
nature to say no we do that better than
you uh oh no we do it our way we're very
happy with our way those walls have come
down to a large extent and there's a
much greater openness uh to look at
things objectively to see what is
working best
i hope that answers your question
councillor sure
thank you councillor
councillor wilkinson
thank you
thank you chair
and um
thank you to council uh um whitney casa
hossack as well for your presentation
thank you as well for the um
the work that's obviously gone into this
in preparation for tonight it's um
there's clearly a lot of stuff that's
done and i personally really appreciate
that so thank you
i'm um i'm very much in favor of this
and i'll make that from the start very
very much in favor of this um i had a
lot of points actually that i wrote down
on the documents that were sent to us
some of which
jonathan's answered in our independent
group meeting we had the other day so
i'm not going to repeat them because
jonathan has actually dealt with some of
the issues i had but there were just a
couple of points i would like to make if
i if i may
um
i note that um
item
7.1 which is the recommendations to full
council
and it does talk about this early one in
the in the document but this is the
recommendation uh point five talks about
the joint chief executive having
delegated authority to undertake
restructure of tiers two and three
now um
one of the points i was going to pick up
and was the fact that nowhere in the
report is there any mention of the chief
officer appointment committee so in
other words there's no mention anywhere
any member involvement whatsoever
in the selection of the strategic
director or the
assistant directors and if there is a
competitive process
then
you would expect there to be some form
of member involvement so i jonathan i
did touching this the other day
but i i did say i'd bring it up and i
would just like there so that to be
noted that whether that that could be
included somewhere on the line
the
forgive me
okay
what we'll do is we'll take all the
questions and okay i've just got one
more point if i make sure thank you of
course um and i think chris you probably
answered this actually but one of the
points i bought i've brought up if i go
to the memorandum of understanding 5.2
you talk about my understanding is that
this is an amalgamation of the back
office
functions of both councils which i think
is absolutely right
then there's twice in that paragraph
talked about harmonizing portfolios
harmonizing functions harmonizing
approaches well that sounds more like a
more like a political perhaps a
political way we move forward and i i
may be completely misreading that
are you talking about harmonizing our
operational approach to things or are am
i reading into that wrongly
thank you
thank you
councillor
councillor wilkinson thank you very much
indeed for your supportive comments
and you give me a really good
opportunity at this stage to pay tribute
to the officer team
of both brentwood and rochford that have
been so
supportive and constructive
and particularly angela hutchings
particularly steve summers strategic
director in brentwood
and of course jonathan stevenson
they have all embraced this project
together with their teams very very
enthusiastically and that all of a
sudden gave a a good feeling about what
we were doing in a feeling that we're
doing right by both of our authorities
so thank you indeed for your
constructive points at the start there
the you make the point about the chief
officer appointments committee and it's
a very fair point um i'll be honest with
you that detail hasn't been gone into
yet as we move through tier one tier 2
tier 3 process it will be important to
put in a process which is
fair
where there is member engagement but i
have to say
given that jonathan was already in post
within brentwood and given the nature of
what we're doing to be blunt the chief
officer appointments committee wasn't an
appropriate vehicle to use in the chief
executive position what i will say is
that he's had the longest interview
process out
in the sense that he's been working with
us for well over six months now uh and
uh i think there are positive comments
all around it's probably fair to say
that i from a rocher point of view have
the most dealings with him uh and um so
it's a it's a different sort of process
um but really when we come to uh the
council meeting towards the end of
january that is when there will be a
formal proposal to adopt him as out i'm
thinking about sorry if you think about
i'm not thinking about jonathan i'm
talking about the ads in the sd card yep
and as i said a little earlier that will
be constructed there will be a process
constructed and there will be member
involvement uh to make sure that the
selection process is
objectively assessed through a member
engagement process
could well be the chief officer
appointments committee the difficulty we
have is we have a number of people on
our chief appointments committee here
brent would have a similar number and it
could be quite intimidating for an
applicant to walk in and sort of see uh
this whole raft of people so there is a
practical aspect to it because we've got
to be uh careful of not overwhelming
individuals it's it's quite a difficult
process to apply for a job as all of us
know uh so we've got to just be a little
bit aware
of the process
but that will be honed as we move
through in terms of your third point i'm
going to pass over if i may chair to us
certainly certainly
well thank you simon um
thank you
your third point if i'm correct was
going into the mou and in 5.2 and you
talked about
uh it read as though it was a
harmonization of
political ambition and i just look at
some of those key words just at the
bottom of 5.2 ambition portfolios
functions and resource
i think for me the what the thing i
would ask is what we saw in the
presentation a moment ago is is your
proposed
strategic objectives for the partnership
i think if broadly you agree with those
and that's what we're proposing that we
share those strategic objectives
then everything else that you'd
harmonize around possibly how you
structure your portfolio to deliver
those objectives how you structure your
functions your resource whether that's
human resource financial resource to
deliver those
then there's no political harmonization
in there it's about do we harmonize the
strategy do we agree with the five key
points therefore what else can we
harmonize to deliver those five key
points and i think if we
we as members in both organizations buy
into those in their bro and they're
quite broad but there's five key themes
if you buy into those then
that's the extent i would suggest of the
harmonization that could be any way be
construed political because they're
delivery gender items themes but beyond
that
i think it's the harmonization certainly
in the sense and in the input i gave to
this document i know simon and others in
this room did
it was really around resource
harmonization if you're pulling in the
same direction then what resource can
you put into that to pull it in that
direction
stronger faster whatever that might be
so that would certainly be my answer
that but just briefly it's certainly my
expectation that members would be
involved in the next level down in the
same way uh and we've got to look at
that in terms of cross-district
representation and cross-party and it
goes to simon's point about let me know
how big is this selection panel so
that's a practical thing that i'm sure
the officers will need to work out thank
you
thank you
councillor foster
thank you chairman and leaders
um
i'm referring to
[Music]
page 6.3.4.2
and page 6.8
0.7.1 paragraph 7 which are related
um
i know the plan to create a
transformation unit with a budget of 300
000 pounds
led by a strategic director
with an externally recruited program
manager
which i think is a great idea i meant to
add that i fully support council workers
support for this program i've got two
questions which are related the first
one is
if this
unit
is to provide advice skills and support
and hit the ground running which i think
is quite important
i assume that current existing staff
from both of the councils will be
recruited to that team
so my my question is really in relation
to that how will their existing
functions in the short term
um be maintained without diminishing
service the second related point is
there was a recommendation in our
discussion last week
to assign an elected member
to the sort of transition unit
both to provide input to it and also
as a conduit for feedback
and
so what are your thoughts on that and
that counselor dre actually raised that
subject and i don't know whether he
wants to add anything to that
sorry chairman that was your job to do
that not mine
thank you chairman yes i i fully support
councillor foster's recommendation that
an elected member
should be
involved in the
transformation unit stroke program
thank you councillor would you like to
answer the points thank you chairman um
the
transformation unit it's actually set
out on
page 6.11
and
that will be a unit which has specific
overview of what we're trying to do it
will be the practical day-to-day unit
that takes this partnership forward the
intention is that as
the various parts of the partnership
evolve develop remember we're talking at
a program that's you know two two and a
half years long so it's you know not
going to happen overnight
which comes back to the point that i
made with councillor shaw you know
nothing is going to we're not going to
make any knee-jerk
actions but um that is really going to
be a stand-alone unit with minimal
minimal draw on resource from existing
operations and that is why it has been
constructed in that way so that there is
a conscious effort
to keep it business as usual service
delivery as usual without affecting the
operational delivery to our residents
and so that is why that unit is is set
up in that way and costed in that way so
that members can actually see the costs
of that unit so it is intended to have
engagement with the various departments
and
operations part so that they're not left
isolated but it is also intended to have
a minimal draw on the operational
service resource so that is the the the
principle there
um
but there will be
uh partnership champions uh being drawn
because you can't work in isolation so
it's actually engagement with but not
having a
draw so there's a diminution in service
delivery so that's that point i think
covered chairman yeah
and in terms of member representation
yeah we've we've thought about this an
awful lot within the work the
preparation work that we've done
and it will be principally for the
leader of brentwood and myself in
rochford to work with the chief
executive in the delivery of this
program
but we are deliberately wanting to keep
the scrutiny process and this is a real
value of the scrutiny process as wide as
possible so that you are continually
engaged in the process and therefore to
start having little units which meet in
behind closed doors we felt wasn't a
good idea
this is open it's transparent and it's
true scrutiny of what we're doing and an
opportunity so
we see unless you tell us differently
through any recommendation we see this
as being the prime body by which we will
be regularly reporting back as well as
to executive and as well as to full
council so the whole process the whole
road map is a transparent open shared
process
thank you
thank you
council stanley
i have to wipe it as we pass it to each
person
thank you chairman
um
i wasn't at
the meeting that you've had
beforehand
as you understand i've looked at this
document and
there are several
pieces in it that i've got to ask
my first question is
how does
the
chief chief officer
johnson
in the way of handling both councils and
in the light of that
should he be head hunted
by another council or anywhere else
where do we go from there in what
respect is there a backup to this
idea that we've got
also the strategic tears that we've got
we're reducing the tears down
considerably and will there be any
redundancies
at pertaining to that
because obviously those people that were
employed at that salary
will they still be employed at that
salary or will there be redundancies
from that
the next question is
is it
on page 6.7 benefits of realization it's
intended that the transport
transformation program will yield an
annual savings of six hundred thousand
to eight hundred and fifty thousand
now
i do understand there is a benefit there
but in the interim period of three years
we are not only have we taken out 300
000 from our our funds and reserves
to operate this
idea
but we're also still losing 300 000
pounds a year on the case that
our budget is three hundred thousand
pounds short well it was it was two
years ago so i was told so i assume that
we still won that we are still on the
three hundred thousand pound less than
what we we're trying to make up
on the basis
on that basis and with the
uh 300 000 pound
that's coming out of general reserves is
is uh 300 000 coming out of the
um
brentwood uh reserves as well to go
towards this equal funds in other words
that's what i'm asking
at the end of this three year period
we've got to each council is 300 000
well
it's taken three years to get three
hundred thousand so
in effect it's only a hundred thousand
pound a year
okay
where do we go from years four five and
six
and seven perhaps where do we see
that saving
if we have inflation
if we have inflation running and
commodities running higher our costs
will be that much higher and where have
we set anything in there in the way of a
percentage to raise those costs
thank you
thank you council standard council would
you like to start off and i think we
might need chairman i'll i'll have a go
and uh
see with my colleagues either side see
whether we can uh um
satisfy councillor stanley and his uh
his questions
um
i think your first point related to
the role that jonathan has undertaken
and how he spreads his resource across
to authorities and well he's done it
very effectively for the last six months
and
that's probably been the hardest part of
it in terms of managing two teams which
haven't in any way been harmonized uh
and brought together uh there will be a
steady process to bring them together
through a partnership arrangement but
actually the hardest part of the job in
the sense of
working with two councils that work in
different ways
and juggling between
the two areas is quite a challenge
but i've also said
that if our most junior staff don't turn
up to work
then
we will have
customer chaos if our bim men don't come
out on a daily basis if our revenues
aren't distributed if our
taxes aren't collected
there will be a problem on day one or
day two
if any senior person doesn't attend work
for a week or two
it probably doesn't matter too much
because it is those senior people that
set the strategic vision set the
ambition work with certainly the two
leaders and the executive and
so there is a different sort of nuance
to the way
senior people work and certainly um
i have been in contact as indeed has
councillor hossack with the chief
executive um on numerous occasions he's
attended
civic meetings
he's attended a whole range of stuff now
that is partly down to the person
that is prepared to
operate between two geographical
locations
but
you know
i think we've got to accept that the
past six months has been the most
difficult moving forward assuming that
we accept the principle of moving
forward in partnership
at the end of january
i think life might become a little
easier for him in terms of
creating
and forming a team which works it's all
about structures isn't it and getting
the most effective structure
in place
look i think within the world of local
government um
good chief executives get head hunted
many many times
in their working life um and
i would be astounded if there weren't
around 10 positions at the present time
in this
when i say region london and the
surrounding area quite a wide area i
would i would be surprised if there were
not 10
positions or more i'm looking for a
possible nod yeah i'm getting a nod
at any one time look it is the reality
of life um but what
um
i hope uh jonathan won't mind me saying
is that you know this has been a concern
for chris and myself that we don't start
on this
partnership
and jonathan turns around and says blah
blah i'm off
but we're confident we've got confidence
but look this is a partnership which is
built on principles and on a robust
platform and is bigger than any single
person around here the leadership
of the two authorities and the and the
executive management team and we've got
to actually put in you know it's one of
the risks
i certainly have confidence
that actually this partnership will
provide uh stimulation and personal
challenge for jonathan to keep him here
for a while yet
but neither chris nor i um
misunderstand the point that um he will
be off but he's given us an insur
assurance that he's really looking
forward to to this and i'll be very
blunt with you and that i wonder whether
if we hadn't come up with this
opportunity
through a process
whether brentwood might have been saying
bye-bye to him a little sooner than they
perhaps are
through at the challenge because
remember often when you get to the
levels of chief exec you're more
motivated by the opportunity and
challenges that these these things give
so so that is that
you ask probably a key and
um really pointed question i cannot look
you in the face
and say that ultimately there will not
be surpluses of staff
we can't have it both ways
we can't each year a look at cutting
services
cutting
staff
and
say well we're looking at an innovative
more creative way of doing things which
deliver service in the current
times that we live in where there's
budgetary constraints so i can't look at
you and say that along the way there may
not be surpluses of staff
what i can look you in the face and say
is that new opportunities will evolve
out of this partnership
we will do our best to slot people in
to existing vacancies because there are
vacancies within both authorities
we will retrain
we will backfill
we will resort to external recruitment
as the last resort
and only when we haven't got people that
we can either retrain or are currently
suitable
and we will avoid redundancies at all
costs it will be the last
position that we have
um and that is no different i would
suggest than any other commercial
environment that that we have i think
i've gone through your various points
but i don't know whether either council
or hossack or johnson wish to add
anything
thank you um chair and thank you to
stanley council woodson um regard to the
financial savings just to give you um
understanding what you've got in front
of you this evening is a report that
talks about phasing of savings against
an overall transformational program of a
full um transition so you're looking at
um the costs of 300 000 pounds per
council and it's 50 50 just to give you
a surety of that is an estimate a
provisional sum of the total cost of
running the partnership for the whole of
the phases that they're in the document
referenced in um in the timeline um but
what you're seeing with regard to the
savings you're seeing
looking at the first phase of savings so
you're looking at total cost with the
first phase of savings so they don't
correlate as as probably as as you say
um those costs are are one-off costs so
they're not they're not there there is a
revenue pressure with them but they're
coming out of
um
reserves originally or for or a one-off
but the cost will only be against a
saving so it's like an investor save so
the first phase if that's delivered in
as you can see in the timeline um in the
document i'll tell you the page
4.3
or 6.4
under 4.3
tier 2 tier 3 process
will look to conclude
before the summer so potentially if the
organization makes the decision at the
end of january to
move forward but that that's what you're
being asked for originally for phase one
to be doing within this paper
that will be undertaken
any future phases with regards to
service delivery will come forward to
this committee
ahead of going to executive or council
or both
and
those decisions will be made with a
financial business case for each of them
so there'll be again a saving potential
with a cost at the moment all we're
doing is giving you the estimate of the
total cost of the program um so again we
if we decide to stop at tier three i'm
not suggesting that's the
right thing to do
um you'll be looking to spend very
little of that of that of that cost for
the program but you'll achieve the
saving between 650 and 800 thousands um
or 650 350 000
so every future business case will come
forward to you as this committee and
then on to council to be made so what
you've got in front of you is the total
cost of the program but only one phase
of the saving and what we haven't
predicted future savings and the reason
we haven't done that is we
we can't estimate them because there may
be some savings but i know both leaders
and both organizations want to be able
the opportunity to look at when they
look at savings potentially put money
into frontline services as well so
rather than put a big figure in and hold
everybody account to a figure the issue
by doing that is if then later date you
might not have the chance to put that
any of those savings back into frontline
services which i know is important to
all members in this chamber or in this
room
i hope that answers regards but i'm
happy to have a follow-up question on
the finance
council
thank you chairman but i i yes i do
realize that there will be savings in
the way of tears
where you are
reducing the employment of in those
tiers that you've got tier two tier
three
however
has been mentioned by
councillor watson
that and i did ask
if there will be a reduction
in salary as well as redundancies and i
do understand that we are going to try
and
effectively effectively try and employ
those people at that ti at that salary
of what they are or
employment i do understand that but they
still they're still not a great savings
is what you what is indicated in here i
don't believe so
yes there will be a saving later on if
the tiers are adhered to
at this present time which will take two
or three years to get to that position
but there's still not a saving
immediately in the way of a saving is
it's a cumulative saving at the end of
three years or four years
so
that's what i'm asking for is that
at this present time there is nothing in
there to say
what the savings are
exactly and what percentage there is in
the future to turn around and say we may
have to
raise this by 10 or 20
because we know what's going on in the
past so we can we have to make
assumptions otherwise we can't you can't
go forward unless you make some sort of
practice of what your budget will be in
year four five and six
so that's what i'm asking and thank you
very much for bringing this up
just that i read this
totally and there was those little
things in it that i needed confirmation
on and thank you very much for answering
okay just just thank you chair and thank
you council stay just a very
clarification just if you look at 6.5
4.9
that gives you that's a these will be
immediate saving so the organizations
are going to one chief exec from two
they're going to three um
strategic directors from four
and then
proposing to go from
12 um full-time equivalents in tier 3 to
9. so that saving is related to that
immediate impact obviously and that's at
the phase running that right up to june
2022
um any future things that are in the box
of service delivery and savings and
that's only the resource saving
obviously having
less people there's there's other other
savings but at the moment for this
report you've only got the resource
savings there's future savings that will
come forward as well
yeah well just a brief comment to add a
bit more to you uh maybe alleviate your
concerns a little bit um
and a good question so thank you but uh
the two probably are linked in terms of
immediate savings and your hypothetical
scenario that if the chief exec was to
leave what was plan b i think
was your comment well plan b is you do
what you any council would do or any
organization which is you go to market
and you find another one it's as simple
as that
but the reassurance that you've got is
this
and it links to your point about
salaries and immediate savings
um
brentwood on its own as a small council
very comparable in many ways in scale to
rochford has a limit as to what it can
pay a chief executive
actually if you start to pull that
and
split 50 50 the cost of a chief exec
there will be an immediate saving on
that one roll to brentwood and
subsequent and yourselves with about 50
000 pounds straight away on one roll
your figurehead roll
um but what that also does from a
recruitment point of view is when you go
into
uh
whatever where they advertise the mj or
whatever it might be
and you're trying to seek the best
talent
what are you more likely to get where
you can it costs you less
to actually pay more because you've
pulled that resource to advertise the
job at a higher financial rate with a
more interesting challenge because it's
a joint chief exec role you're more
likely to attract new talent so i it's
hypothetical i you know we we can only
talk in hypothetics i'm quite confident
that uh
that jonathan wants to make his mark and
make this partnership a success should
we go forward and do it so i can do that
that's just subjective i can't commit to
that but that's certainly my take on
things but if plan b is needed you'd go
and do it i think we could do it
confidently because trying to attract a
joint chief exec to a better salary
attracts better talent to a more
interesting job than just being the
chief exec there or say of a small
district so that that's that's what i
say so i've tried to link both of your
points into into that so
for what it's worth chair thank you that
was my comment thank you
mr shaw
thank you chairman um my
question is um item 8 on 6.8 6.9
which is the risk implications
um
as it says here that the what we've got
at the moment is just
a simple analysis of the most obvious
risks and it does say that um going
forward obviously there's going to be
more risks which have got to be defined
and mitigated naturally managed and i
think actually council wooden has
answered my question um which was going
to be going forward would
the
new risk
register be shared with this committee
and i think he already said that
he wants us to be involved in it so
he has um i think answered my question
already
thank you councilman would you like to
add any more i think
i think his
okay thank you councillor drei
[Music]
thank you chairman
and firstly i support this partnership
and i would like to thank and
congratulate all those who has got
who've got us to this stage mr chairman
um i've got a comment in respect of item
4.5 on page 6.4
it refers to the s113
agreement which will also contain
provisions relating to can discontinuing
the arrangements if required in the
future
obviously i hope that won't come about
but i would nonetheless like to see the
s113 agreement
include provision for the early
for the early development of a robust
exit agreement in order to protect both
councils including their assets
and staff thank you chairman thank you
councillor would you like to answer that
please
you chairman uh thank you councillor dre
um
the answer is yes
because
the robustness of a section 113 document
has to be
very clear in terms of the legalization
of the whole of the process
but one thing
that
we have to address
it's a little bit like
councillor stanley's point in terms of
staff
sometimes it's a little uncomfortable
when we're talking about the
creation of a partnership to start
talking about the possibility of a
divorce
it's not normally what you do when
partners come together
and they enjoy the early romance to talk
about how it might end
but it is responsible for us to consider
within this partnership a what-if
situation
and that will be born
into the
103 document
and tied up in in legal terms
but one of the things that
we have to do responsibly is to make
sure within our financial
arrangements
we always are prepared for the day
when there might be a change for
whatever reason that could come through
government legislation
it could come through reorganization
it could come through political change
it could come through to and that could
be on either authority it could come
through officer change
and dare i say sometimes through
personality changes so we have to be
realistic
that
this isn't something that we're talking
about you know
anytime soon but certainly there are
authorities that have come together it's
worth pointing out that there are
different
sorts of partnerships right across the
country i think there's about 40
councils in some sort of partnership
arrangement and those are
very varied partnership of services
shared
arrangements with chief executives
mergers of authorities that have
commonality in their boundaries there's
all sorts of different different forms
but
to talk about the divorce and um
responsibly uh face the possibility that
one day for whatever reason we may not
be together uh will be sewn into the 113
agreement but to come back to your
earlier point the answer is simply yes
that document will be made available to
members i don't know whether
any officers or
jonathan wish to add to that at all
thank you chairman um yes i can confirm
that the 113 agreement was the
delegation and recommendations to the
leaders
and to the um monitoring officers to
create and formulate that document that
that document will of course be executed
on behalf of the council members um will
be entitled to citizen perhaps maybe i
would suggest it's a recommendation that
this committee might like to make that
it comes to this this committee
thank you
uh council mrs gadsden
could you
have the microphone
sorry
is a mediation process when there is um
conflict
to a way to resolve conflict between the
parties
um whatever the process that seems
suitable
thank you
councilwoman would you like to
comment or just agree yep okay great
that's simple thank you
council constable please
[Music]
thank you mr chairman
i've got it it's more of a concern on
i've just been looking here at the one
of the roles on one of the assistant
directors and
the amount of
jobs he's got i'm concerned
that
if
he then takes on roles at brentwood
somewhere down the line
um someone will come along and say oh my
portfolio or my work is now too large i
need an assistant to the assistants
and we end up with another level of
bureaucracy in the council because of
the duplication perhaps someone could
answer that one for me please counselor
thank you councillor constable thank you
chairman we have that situation at the
present time the simple fact is that
within rochford some of our jobs are too
big
but it is
and i'm talking about for assistant
directors
and
you know this is a span of control that
really concerns the executive at the
present time and this is where we
believe that a proper structure with
proper management structures heads of
service
can actually address that so really this
whole
partnership provides an opportunity to
look at a team which will provide
what i would suggest is a proper
management structure other than
a structure which is constrained by
costs and i know that might sound a
rather odd thing to say but what this
does is it provides the opportunity for
economies of scale
so if you're
writing policy if you're writing
documents often there will be the
opportunity to
have similar documents across the two
authorities so you do achieve economies
of scale
but
it is a concern to the executive team
exactly the point that you've made that
we feel the spans of control for some of
our existing assistant directors is too
wide and possibly a little unfair
and i have expressed concern
certainly to the chief exec
that i worry about there is a welfare
issue here and i worry about the extent
of some of the work that gets referred
to our senior people and i think we've
actually got to put in a process where
members certainly feel that residents
concerns that come through members don't
always have to go to the top of the tree
they can tap in
to certain levels so i think it's a very
very fair point that you make but
actually i think quickly this
partnership can address that through
providing more job opportunity job
interest
across to authorities but perhaps
reducing the spans of control
because if you actually analyze what
some i can't speak for brentwood but
certainly in rockford i'm frankly amazed
at what some of our assistant directors
do and i pay tribute to them but i
sometimes wonder uh whether or not in
welfare terms we're doing the best by
some of our officers and i think this is
one of the areas that i think we can
provide real opportunity and actually
give our assistant directors and other
managers the opportunity to sort of
reflect but i think they're at times
firefighting and all of us may have been
in that situation in our professional
lives where that's not where you get job
satisfaction if you're constantly
chasing your tail so a really good point
thank you councillor constable
thank you councilwoman councillor mrs
mcpherson
thank you chairman um
my questions are relating to page 6.6
phase two the alignment of service
delivery and creation of joint working
um
especially in relation to 4.7
i have a couple of questions
um as we continue or the partnership
would continue its uh journey
there will be
lessons to learn through that process
a question have we actually talked to
other authorities who've been through
this process
and asked them about some lessons that
they may
have learned that they could share their
expertise and experience with us
and also will there be a
continued learning log kept
so that
we can make a note of the experiences as
we move services forward
detailing the actions taken and then
bringing that
log back to this committee
thank you
council and council jose i guess
thank you uh
councilman mcpherson um
look you're absolutely right
i expect as we move down
the experience path here
we will use experience to reflect and we
may hopefully not too often say we could
have done that better but i'm afraid
that is one of life's principles um but
really what we have already done is
we've had long sessions with both
bromsgrove and redditch we've got a
partnership
we've also talked extensively to south
norfolk and broadlands
they're quite different partnerships
and we've also spent a lot of time
talking to ilga east of england local
government association
to
test their experience of working with
councillors that are going through this
process but for me to sit here and say
to you that everything is going to be
hunky-dory and rosie
i might be accused of being somewhat
misleading
so we're aware of some of the pitfalls
we've got one or two quite good
documents that actually
certainly brahmsgrove and redditch
prepared
actually highlighting to us some of the
things that went particularly well some
of the things that didn't go
particularly well um and
there will be issues but
i think the issues that occur
yes we can learn from experience but
some of them i don't think there's i
think there are unique experiences in
terms of uh issues that perhaps the
political makeup can give change of
political makeup when we have elections
every year there may be new thinking
that affects that so but
coming back to the documentation uh the
risk and making sure that we log this
sort of stuff absolutely right we need
to build those registers as we move
through hopefully that answers your
question
person thank you
thank you council
sorry yeah thank you chair uh just just
to just to build on that a little bit
more yes we spoke to bromsgrove and
reddish the thing that struck me about
that was a that conversation
particularly struck in my mind because
they've been a partnership for 10 years
and they were able to
articulate to us where they were be
while they were coming together like we
are to contemplate
why do we need the partnership in the
first place what benefits could do we
think we'd realize and just listening to
them
in terms of what they were going through
a decade ago is exactly where we are now
they're 10 years into it and what they
were able to say is actually we've
realized pretty much all of what we
anticipated too so that was that was
really an encouraging conversation yes
we spoke to south norfolk importance but
not losing sight the fact that i touched
on it earlier i mean
jonathan has come from to brentwood from
mid-south for competitors so has worked
there's an experience in there already
as well so there's that was absolutely
part of our due diligence and uh i feel
quite confident having
had those conversations which were
really frank actually
um talking about the pitfalls as well as
the opportunities
that it was quite reassuring that i felt
personally we're on the right track
particularly when you're talking to a
partnership with 10 years old which was
which was quite nice
thank you
thank you
no other members are indicating are
there any further questions
okay mrs gadsden
first of all i'd like to say that i do
support this partnership
i feel we've been trading water for some
time balancing our budgets and with
inflation running higher than the rises
in our council's annual income
i think we've been presented with the
challenge of how to balance the books
without cutting services further so i'd
like to
congratulate everyone involved
with the idea of this
proactive rather than a reactive
solution to the problems that we're
facing
um my questions are
um
whilst we don't feel that or with we
don't feel there may be an impact on
services
i'd like to wonder if we how we're going
about reviewing how the
partnership is affecting our residents
and the services we've provided
i'd like to recommend that we have a
feedback process that
we measure and collate through services
via surveys social media online etc so
that we continuously monitor the process
and the partnership how it's affecting
our residents throughout the transition
period and beyond
thank you um
i don't apprehend this but uh councillor
and i had a conversation the other day
and one of the things was that
during the transformation i guess
i'm not putting words into your mouth
hopefully
but some of this won't necessarily be
that visible in the early stages um to
residents but
going forward
chairman you're not putting words into
into my mouth and i think councillor
gadsden also makes a really good point
and and i think she's actually
potentially added to a recommendation
and
look
we're in that
business i'm afraid where
so much of what we do if we do it right
and we do it correctly is rather taken
for granted
and so in terms of how we make the
difference for our residents i would
suggest if their bins aren't collected
if the grass isn't cut if we don't do
the services that they see
every day that is when we will hear
about it
when we make incremental improvement
whilst we will acknowledge that through
the formal meetings agendas that we have
and there will be
i would suggest
to jonathan that we put certain red
amber green measures in place in terms
of the delivery of our services
it might be a little
shall i say disappointing um that we
haven't got residents rushing up to us
every two minutes and sort of saying hey
that partnership is really making the
difference so i don't want to sort of
create this uh optimism that everyone's
going to be running up to us
what both councillor hossack and i will
be holding the chief executive to
account for is that there is no
degradation in service that really
concerns me
but at the same time i want to see areas
where this partnership is making a
difference to the lives of our residents
and our businesses and i do want some
system put in place which captures that
opportunity otherwise frankly members we
might as well go home
okay no other members are indicating um
so i'd like to move now to
recommendations
bearing in mind i'd like you to be as
clear as possible because uh
angela hutchings it will be trying to
document this so um those certainly
council mrs gadslin you've certainly
made two recommendations would you like
to
articulate those again please
i i my recommendation was that there's
an ongoing need for reviewing the impact
of the partnership and services through
some sort of
feedback through measuring through
collating information from surveys
social media online web
sites etc
the recommendation was about um
resolution of disputes remediation and
the process been outlined
it should be included in the
document yeah
um to solve partnership documents yeah
okay thank you
any other recommendations
council drain thanks
thank you chairman
um i would like to propose a
recommendation that we consider the
development of a robust exit agreement
within the s 113 agreement
thank you very succinct thank you
any other recommendations
if you'll indulge me i'd like to i'm
sorry cancel against them
we've been assured that the costs will
be shared evenly between both councils
and
i don't know if it's a recommendation
but will the information be will the
quantitative and quantitative data be
produced and put towards the audit
committee so that this can be reviewed
i think that's in two parts so there is
a recommendation if it isn't going to be
so council on the council hossei
will that be in place
it will be so yeah certainly
okay any other recommendations members
okay if you'll indulge me i've got a
recommendation
being made on behalf of a member that
couldn't be here
and it relates to page 6.9 power 6.2
and it's within the risk
um
so register um it's to do with
technological
and um the recommendation
is that um although
part of the mitigation is to do due
diligence
in phase two i would like to recommend
that this is one of the first activities
in phase two because it's not just a
risk it's also an opportunity and it's a
bit the the technology potentially is
the building block for the other
services as well so i would say
if we can bring that early within phase
two
thank you for your indulgence
okay members no one else is indicating
with any recommend further
recommendations so what i propose to do
is we'll have a short break um probably
angela how long do you think
if i so we'll take a quick five minute
uh i was going to say smoke break but
that's not uh
it's not the right language so we'll
have a quick five minute uh leg stretch
and then we'll come back we'll agree the
recommendations and then we will vote on
the
report thank you
okay thank you welcome back members um
can you all see the screen if you can't
please move around so you can see so
we've got four recommendations on the
screen uh which will come from this
meeting
i'll read them out just to
show off my new glasses
first recommendation is the section 113
agreement makes provision for robust
exit arrangements and the member-led
conflict resolution process
is that agreed
okay okay
um second one is that the section 113
agreement
comes to the review committee for
scrutiny before it is executed
okay getting nods good
number three the feedback from residents
as the impacts of the partnership on
services is regularly sought and
reported upon
right and then the last one that there
were
there'd be an early review of technology
in phase two of the transformation
program to identify threats and or
opportunities
so that's my one so yes
okay
um
members there are two recommendations at
paragraph 12.1 on page
6.1
of the report
which is basically saying that it's the
recommendations of paragraph 7 of the
report plus
any recommendations from our committee
so members
with a show of hands those that are in
favor
of the recommendation please indicate
okay that is unanimous thank you
um and at 12.2 subject to paragraph 12.1
the review committee recommends to
council to adopt the contents of this
report
can those members in favor please raise
their hands
okay that is unanimous thank you members
um
councillor wootton um
asked me whether it would be okay to
show you the recommendations that came
out of last night's meeting from
brentwood borough council so um
angela thank you
do you want me to read them out
so the recommendations are that the mou
and or other documents that underpins
the strategic partnership
makes provision for member-led conflict
resolution process
that the mou and or other document that
underpins the strategic partnership
makes clear that whilst the division of
the savings achieved as part of the
transformation process is to be agreed
between the two councils
the starting point for that discussion
should be 50 50
and that further detail and
clarification be provided as to the
savings estimated to be achieved by the
partnership
how this would be achieved the phasing
of such savings and in which financial
years they would be realized
so
not far off no
okay right
thank you members so moving back on to
the agenda
we move on to agenda item seven which is
the key decisions document and as always
we'll we'll go through this one page at
a time and if anyone wishes to
raise anything please let me know
so the
first one is 0
4 stroke 2 1
which is the voluntary sector grant
allocations 20 22
23
okay no one is indicating thank you
key decision 1321
south essex parking partnership
no one is indicating i think that's all
of the
yeah okay thank you moving on to agenda
item 8
which is the work plan
do any members have any comments on the
work plan or do you think they wish to
be considered for inclusion
okay no one is indicating um but i am
conscious that um
we had a review of the review committee
and that we set up or we
allocated members to a working group
and when i've looked through the report
in detail
there are a number of steps that we're
already taking so for example one of the
steps was to set up pre-meetings we were
already doing that and there's a lot of
stuff that goes on behind the scenes
that only the vice chair and i really
see which is
the meetings that we have now with
regular meetings with officers
with the chief executive and with
the leader of the council and the deputy
leader of the council so those were
recommendations that don't really
have been carried forward but they don't
really need a working group to do that
but there are a couple of pieces of work
that i do believe would benefit from
wider the wider working group which is
to come up with our sort of code of
conduct our operating procedures
and also the training so i'd like
members to be thinking about the
training needs and development needs for
members of the review committee and so
that's where we are on that
anyone
like any further information
nope okay in that case
sorry
okay
in that case that um concludes all of
the
items on the agenda
and so
the
meeting is closed at
21 19
thank you